Louise it sounds like then it was part
therapy having more egg and Emma come in
to the house and at the same time maybe
people do need to know that they will be
sort of under a microscope and how
uncomfortable that could be in
preparation I think Neal made it his
therapy in a way and as I think and
certainly Morrigan mo wouldn't have
brought the camera anywhere that we
didn't want it to go I'm virtually more
I can able left us with a camera in the
house as well and Neal started to become
very demanding about that camera coming
out for certain situations and he really
wanted to show I think he really wanted
to show the worst of that disease and
some of its just too difficult to watch
though I meanness it's an incredibly
difficult disease to manage and
certainly with the speed that it ripped
through Neal it's a very difficult
disease to keep up with and even
professional services find it really
hard to keep up with so I think that was
why he was wanting to you know sure this
on camera at possibly that was his
therapy to touch they feel that he was
educating people and but I think for us
it didn't feel intrusive umm ayman and
Morag well more I had been a friend for
years and I'd personally worked in the
film industry neal had always been
extremely keen to get involved in his
friends student films and things like
that so weak these things weren't alien
to us we were aware that you know of
equipment and things like that I think
if you if you didn't have a little bit
of prior knowledge than it may it might
be something that you need to the coat
for a bit and certainly when you was
talking to
the camera then I got my extra five
minutes with Oscar and you know I got to
have a little plea and it was generally
quite good for us do you remember the
day you had the conversation about
agreeing to do the film and I do it it
wasn't as much as a conversation it was
basically one question I think more egg
had sent me an email very kind of
tentatively putting us across and I can
just remember my email back without even
talking to Neal I mean and I did
eventually if I was just like gorgeous
after the day we've had please come down
here he needs to talk he needs to he
needs to communicate about this disease
and I knew you would he would want to do
it so it was a very short conversation
and but the timing was very much focused
on immediate things like newspaper
articles and local TV news were coming
out to interview US and very frustrated
if a newspaper had shelf just shelved
her story and for a more appropriate
space in their paper and I think he
realized that the documentary would be
the thing that would carry on a lot
longer hmm so it was kind of touching
gold that it was that thing though you
know it wasn't given even though Neal
was amazing to the Camerons almost
Louise actually it would be still and it
was still quite hard eight of raise
money and beaten to make it work as a
story because you can imagine it's still
quite intense suffering to to reach an
audience and of course lots of countries
would say we have these stories in our
country why should we look at this and
so really i think what saved the film
what made it a more universal story was
his blog and the fact that he wrote
these incredible words that we could use
throughout the film and I think that's
when we realized that we had a bigger
film that we
could actually reach a much wider
audience with because it was really rare
that somebody was so fresh and honest
about their experience so witty his
writing is so wedding so I think that
helped create a much more interior world
than the film in your advice for another
documentarian who would come into
anyone's life situation and film it is
it to come with a set of questions be
ready to ask them but also just let
whatever is going to happen I think come
with your doubts i think in come with
your questions about yourself and what
you're doing I think you have to be
really clear what what your position is
in terms of this and that's what gives
you the right then to push further but I
think until you're really clear in
yourself then you don't know why you're
filming and I think it was that clarity
that really then you don't need to
prepare your questions it's really
because that's all part that all comes
from the same place so I don't think
it's so much about a sort of outward
preparation as an inward one in terms of
thinking but and then of course talking
to Louisa knew about what do we agree
this film is and you know what is
acceptable to film what isn't acceptable
and and we talked a lot to new about how
would he represent her if he was filming
this
you